hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review i have a review for you
today
a lot of you have requested that i test
these uh
ac power regenerators specifically the
units from ps audio
and that's what i have for you today uh
is this unit back here is their uh i
think highest end unit they make i think
maybe there's a p15 but this is the p12
um
uh power regenerator power plant they
call it and
a
member kindly send it to me it's pretty
expensive uh let me show you the review
on site
um
it's the cost is about fifty five
hundred dollars i don't know if they
charge uh shipping on top of that so
not for faint of hard as for us expenses
are concerned i'm sure many of you have
audio systems that cost less than this
and here you have this box um as the
name indicates the job of this machine
is to take ac input
and generate ac again
with the idea that the ac that it
generates is much cleaner than what
comes out of your wall
if you look at the back of the unit it
has this incoming ac plug that you plug
into and then you have outlets for both
low current and high current
output
you can see this got a very nice user
interface with this meter you can see
the statistics with respect to the
quality of the
ac input and ac output although i'll
show you how
later on that that the instrumentation
has is not very accurate
um
it doesn't have uh any uh doesn't make
any noise at low current but if you look
underneath there are two giant uh fans
in here uh imagine if you try to hook up
a power amplifier or something to it uh
it will uh
start wailing pretty loud well i
shouldn't say pretty loud i didn't hear
him come on so but with two fans i
suspect won't be you know that quiet so
if the fans do come on you're trading uh
ac noise for uh
fan noise
um the unit almost tore a hole in my
finger i was putting it on the side as
you can see for this picture and when i
want to put it down as i was supporting
it to let it sort of slide uh
horizontally my finger cut where i've
written extremely sharp this sheet metal
just goes to a point and it's razor
sharp uh and there's another one on top
here it's basically a machining mistake
this these two points should have been
connected so there is no uh uh you know
point that ends
on top of it uh you know potentially uh
cutting your finger um that point is
also has no support this is just hang in
the breeze so you can snag on things and
just bend and
uh messed that up although i'm sure you
could bend it back but for fifty four
hundred dollars i would expect to not
see mistakes like this it's a very
simple machining mistake uh you just
never leave unsupported piece of thin
sheet metal hanging out here but other
than that going back to the unit it's
it's a very very nice looking industrial
design the top of it i don't know if you
can see uh it's sort of a black acrylic
material
it's quite heavy i think it's 47 pounds
2456 kilograms uh
and the reason it's so heavy is that
this is basically a monoblock it's
almost like a seven or 800 watts single
channel para amplifier that's all it is
it takes ac input converts it to dc
and then it feeds a power amplifier and
a power amplifier is fed instead of
audio signal normal music it's fed with
the 60 hertz or whatever you set the
frequency to and it amplifies that
frequency and generates a sine wave you
put sine wave in you get sine wave out
so if you had a
you know almost a thousand watt
amplifier you could have your own ac
generator if you will um this is a
little bit more custom designed with
protection circuits and everything
designed for this application but at the
end of the day that's all it is it's a
power amplifier sitting in front of your
audio equipment
and uh but being an amplifier you can
have feedback and you can control
distortion and noise and
be cleaner than
what the incoming ac looks like
i've quoted the reviews in here as
always
and the product specs so it was fun to
see what the manufacturer talks about
it says that it has perfect sine wave i
don't know
hopefully they're talking generically
because there is no such thing as
perfect anything even the
state-of-the-art audio equipment won't
be perfect so you know taking some
liberty with wording in here but i'll
let him go
um but i can't let go is this claim here
that if you use this thing you have
better micro macro dynamics cleaner and
lower background noise of course none of
this is supported in in their uh
documentation uh to follow
i mean measurements to follow
um as you look at these measurements i
have uh
different terminology i use raw ac mains
means the ac that i have sitting in here
that i use for my powering my computer
uh powering my analyzer and whenever i
test something it also gets plugged into
that
outlet so
um from that point of view it's it's the
ac that you would have of course
everybody's ac will be different
different levels of noise but as you'll
see mine has firm and distortion noise
to allow this device to produce the
effect that it it says it does
then the next thing is that you know
that ac i either test directly what that
looks like or then feed it to the uh ps
audio p12
and look at its output and see how the
two contrast
so those are two pieces now to really
analyze what this device can or cannot
do
i also took a couple of audio power
supplies one switching one linear and i
plugged the meter to the raw
ac mains or the output of ps audio to
see if the power supply output becomes
cleaner that's what everybody assumes
happens when you clean up the ac then
the power that's inside your audio
coping becomes cleaner too
and we want to see if that really
happens or not or whether it's just lay
intuition that's not correct
um
and then finally i test all the way at
the end of the pipeline which is what we
really care about we don't listen to ac
raw ac we don't listen to the dc power
supply inside of our machines
we listen to analog outputs so the
question if i just took a question is
whether if i just took a piece of audio
device and plugged into my dirty ac and
then plugged into the powerplant uh p12
from ps audio
will this analog app would improve
because that's what we listen to and if
that doesn't improve then it doesn't
matter how good it job it does elsewhere
it's just not going to be good
so let's first
cover a little bit about instrumentation
how do i test something like this um i'm
in 120 volt ac in the united states
that's an rms voltage so peaks of it is
1.44 times uh
that's about 160 170
um
and how do you analyze 170 volt signal
my audio precision analyzer can actually
go up to i think 150 volts uh so 170
volts would damage it and
i'm in no mood to damage a 30 000
instrument
so instead of just testing it directly
um i have a what's called a differential
probe at that it's as a step down
hundred to one step down in it so i can
hook up this differential probe to ac
mains directly and then the output of it
is 100 times smaller so
um when i do that that allows me to then
have instead of 112 120 volts i can have
1.2 volts which is well within the
measurement capability and what the
audio precision likes to see
and
the fact is differential means that it
has two lines and
and those two if you if
any noise is picked up by those wires if
it's the same in both of them it ignores
them so it's very important to have
noise immunity in measurements like this
because we're dealing with mains and hum
and things like that we don't want our
probing and instrumentation to actually
be you know interfering with that
but uh just like any other piece of
electronics this device itself has its
own noise and distortion so
let's first measure how much distortion
and noise this probe does so i'm not
dealing with ac at all right now all
i've done is that i've
hooked up my signal generator from my
audio precision set it to 26 volts
output which is the highest output it
can generate and then i capture the
input and just like any other device i
can measure its distortion and
noise and everything else and that's
this is what it looks like um i have 26
volts so it gets divided by 100 so it's
0.26 volts now so
you know 100 to 1 function is happening
the distortion in this is quite low
especially for this class of the
probe is point zero zero eight percent
or nine percent distortion those of you
know about cyanide
uh in my measurements about 81 db
synapse so it anything that approaches
81 db would be no good as far as
measuring with this probe because the
probe itself will have more distortion
fortunately that's not the case we're
dealing with pretty dirty signals uh
when it comes to ac so first let's hook
up this probe to my uh
ac mains the raw ac as i mentioned
um it shows 1.2 volts remembers 100
times lower than the reality so in
reality is 123 volts is my incoming ac
the distortion that i uh
getting is almost two percent distortion
and the cyanide is 34 db
so
my probe hasn't has basically zero
impact on this kind of measurement as
you can see the spectrum here is quite
dirty i have the main
source of power which is the 60 hertz in
the united states that is the the
desired signal we want but
also with it comes all this other noise
and spikes uh most of them are harmonics
so this is at uh
120 hertz uh if i'm reading that
correctly uh
right here 120 hertz this little one
then 180 hertz and uh just keep
multiplying by 60. and the worst
offending ones are these spikes up here
now as far as level you can see there's
minus 40 in here so this
other spikes around -38 or so
and hence the reason sign out for this
uh my raw ac is about 34 db
let me make this a little smaller so we
can see the whole display at once yeah
um
so
you know does ac mains need to be
cleaner than this
turns out no but
but we have it so let's let's go along
if i hook up this raw ac and hook it up
to uh
uh the p12 the ps audio a series
generator and it reads the input 123
volts which is fine uh it says that my
incoming uh
thd
which i assume is thc plus n but it may
just be thd it's 1.7
remember i measured 2
so it's underestimated and under
measuring the uh thd by 0.2 percent so
know that this is not a lab grade
measurement device uh
you know the whatever the thd meter do
they have in there quick and dirty but
maybe it just measures harmonics and not
noise mine includes noise in there also
um
then it also says that it's generating
0.1 output so
let's go ahead and and plug in that
my raw ac that i just instrumented um to
p12
and then see what happens so
we read 120 volts which is nice it's
regulating the output of exactly 120
volts
distortion is now 0.4 percent or 0.46
percent instead of um 2 so we have about
uh four times less distortion coming out
of p12 compared to my raw main so it
clearly is is much cleaner output and we
can see that in the spectrum over here
um the highest peak is now at minus 52
db and remember before was like minus 38
or something so quite a bit cleaner it
knocked down but it is still generating
quite a bit of noise
in here and speaking of noise which i'll
come back to if you look at the bottom
in here this noise is actually higher
than my incoming ac so which is very
strange so this device is actually
rather noisy uh you know everybody buys
this with impression that it's got lower
noise but turns out that low frequencies
is noisier than my raw ac without using
it so we'll come back to that um
as i mentioned that the uh they
the box thinks it's outputting 0.1
percent thd but we're seeing five times
as much at 0.5
so don't trust that measurement that's
really being optimistic and doing itself
a favor fortunately the spec is 0.5
and it's within spec so no complaint
other than you know the meters in it are
not accurate and it's trying to make you
feel better about the signal than than
it really is um you can see the signal
the frequency is pretty accurate the 60
hertz 59.99
and uh all is well there so now let's
just look at the full spectrum of what
we see uh in here because we want to
know the nature of the noise that's
coming out of our ac so
in blue is is my raw incoming ac so i'm
analyzing it from 20 hertz at 20
kilohertz with high resolution
fft so it tells us all the components of
raw ac and it's basically what used to
be in the dashboard but done in a higher
resolution so this spike goes up here
remember this is our 60 hertz which is
our energy and then all this other noise
and unwanted signals then in red i have
the output of the p12 now in here is if
you look to the right a little bit
harder to see but uh oops
sorry
um but the spikes have been lowered uh
by p12 these red bars are
you know lower amplitude than the than
the blue one but if you look at in here
actually the noise level has risen this
is my incoming ac in blue and this is
inc
output of the p12 so it's added good few
dbs of noise in here
and uh this is all in audio band so
contrary to what they said is a blacker
background and what have you
it's actually generating more noise uh
coming out of it unless how does it
generate noise again remember it's an
amplifier it's a power amplifier it's a
high power amplifier and any amplifier
has noise unless you design really well
i own a p300 which is a 20-year-old
version of this technology and it didn't
have this problem it was just as clean
as you know i'll show you later on i was
my instrumentation so this is a step
backwards uh
you know from that point of view
so
uh that's a problem but we'll get into a
bigger problem
i actually have a
bnk uh 9801 lab ac generator this is an
instrument that
people who deal with ac
will buy and is able to
you can program generate any ac output
you want any voltage any phase uh can
have 60 hertz 52 hertz 72 hertz
and i can even distort the signal
heavily and so if you're designing some
kind of electronic equipment and you
want to know how sensitive it is to
bakeries of of ac you use this kind of
instrument uh it's a 2600 device and
it's only 300 watts so about a third of
the power output of the uh
ps audio p12 so
um
but its job is the same you know it
generates ac and
i can measure its performance just as
well as we measured p12 and look at the
cyanide that it generates it's 65 db
again let's go back to the sign out of
the p12 and it's 46 db
so it is generating a far far cleaner
output and indeed you can see that now
the worst case offender
out of my uh lab generates minus 70 db
from our main 60hz so it's a far far
cleaner signal
than this box is generating now if the
p12 was a i don't know a thousand dollar
device would be one thing but if you're
gonna charge almost six thousand dollars
for it it better be as good as a lab
instrument otherwise why are you buying
this box go buy my lab generator is half
the price so twenty six hundred dollars
almost and it is far cleaner than the
p12 so if your
main use of these boxes is to hook them
up to uh your dac or preamp or turntable
what have you you're much better off
going to people actually are in the
business of making uh clean ac and bk
precision is one of them not that many
companies actually make these products
but
there are three or four brands out there
and
at anyway
as i said earlier i was surprised that
the the quality of the output ac output
is not very good in this audio in this
ps audio uh their previous devices i
thought were almost as good as my uh
bk precision 9801 so that's a
disappointment so right here we could
just draw the line and say ps audio you
told us you built a great uh ac
regenerator regenerator and you didn't
do that you just got a
okay it's a halfway between raw ic and
my lab
uh generator and for this kind of money
you better give me the same pristine uh
low distortion uh
signal so
that's that's disappointing from that
point of view so even if you buy into
this thing you you know you you haven't
gotten what you should have gotten let's
compare the spectrum of the two again
this is my lab generator compared to the
p12 look at where the noise floor is in
my lab generator
it's just a stunning amount of
difference with red being the p12
it's just night and day cleaner uh
you know it just doesn't make sense that
is the performance of p12 is so poor
i think they take advantage of the fact
that nobody ever does this kind of
competitive analysis of these products
and so
you know nobody pays attention to it and
i don't even know if they're measuring
it this as well as i am measuring it and
uh
by the way if there are dedicated
devices that measure and characterize
power line devices
and uh somebody actually suggested in
the thread that you know should be i
should have used that you should not use
it for this kind of analysis the audio
precision analyzer that i have in the
audio band has incredible dynamic range
and low noise and what have you and
that's why it's able to resolve the
noise floor of my ac generator with no
trouble if you use a line generator
ac mains analysis tools those have very
poor performance compared to what i have
so maybe that's what psid is relying on
using it and not using state-of-the-art
equipment with the proper technique to
find out that they're actually adding
noise to the
ac bands rather than reducing it so
anyway as an ac generator is espec
is it a fail yeah at this price is a
fail uh
you know it's just nothing to hang your
head on
um
there are two modes of operation in
there one of them is called low
distortion the other one is called uh
high regulation high regulation being
that it it make sure the output is
always at 120 or whatever you set it to
i think it's pro combo
and then the other mode is the lowest
distortion at the expense of letting
regulation go up and down and
i tested the two and you can see them
over here i am not detecting any
difference uh
uh in there uh it's possible if you load
it way down the output may sag
in one mode versus the other i don't
know but from a point of view of
impacting my instrumentation it makes no
difference uh and i use the default mode
which is the high regulation mode but
again notice that it's the same
from point of view of instrumentation
that i've been showing you
so
this is showing all three of them now on
top of each other
so
we can see that at low frequencies the
red is
the ps audio and it's actually worst of
uh
up three which is the raw ac and the
last one is is the lab generator but at
higher frequencies than my raw ac is the
worst you can see the blue peaks in here
and the red is the um
the p12 so it definitely is better but
you know again it doesn't have uniform
reduction in noise
so
when i've been posting this power
measurements for a
myriad of other devices that i've tested
people always come back and say well
maybe the output of the power supply got
cleaner how do you know it didn't get
cleaner maybe if you had a different
piece of audio equipment it would have
made it cleaner and what have you so
this time i decided to address that
which is i took two external power
supplies
one was a little switching power supply
a little small one that came with a dac
and headphone amp for topping the x3 pro
excuse me and it's a switching power
supply means universal input and it's
very compact and high efficiency and
many audio devices use switching power
supplies and so let's look at the output
of it so the output of it is nominally
dc meaning there is no nothing else but
the pure
line but in reality everything has noise
and and uh other uh spurious uh
uh
yeah unwanted signals in it so let's go
ahead and and
again in the audio band which is what we
care about see what comes out of that
power supply
we see that it's got a little bit of a
mains hum
at 60 hertz in here which is expected
and then the worst thing though is this
one spike in here uh around one point
some killers between one and two killers
i don't know where that comes from in
this power supply hard to know what runs
at that frequency but whatever it is is
65 decibels below zero below the dc
level so it's already very very weak
signal uh but it does stand out
and uh maybe somebody will claim that's
from the ac input
so let's plug in um this by the way is
from my raw ac when i'm just plugging
into a wall directly
then i take the same power supply and
now i run it the ac through the ps audio
p12 ac regenerator and then compare the
two and as you can see the red and the
blue graphs land right on top of each
other if anything looks like the red is
actually a little bit worse in here
um but otherwise all this nastiness if
you want to call it that they all remain
cleaning the input didn't have any
uh
improvement on the output why because
this stuff was generated by the power
supply itself
after ac
not before so
what it generates itself obviously the
incoming signal can't impact
and uh so in case of this switching
power supply there's no improvement at
all with a series generator uh
on this thing the second test i did was
a linear power supply that's probably a
lot more common and than a switching
power supply and audio gear so for that
i don't know yeah i have it i
use this uh power supply that comes
with my grass
headphone measurement system this 15 000
measurement system that
i use to measure headphones and it comes
with what i assume to be a
decent external block this actually
powers this preamp
uh on this thing that and also the power
for the microphones so i went ahead and
measured that and i'm showing you the
three different measurements over here
um
if we look in here you see that
it has a 120 hertz spike over here which
is the worst offending output from it
then there are some more multiples of
that the reason we get 120 hair spike is
that a
linear power supply or basically any
power supply generates dc
first takes the
sine wave that goes up and down both
positive and negative first it flips the
negative to the positive so now you have
positive humps rather than positive and
negative in a sine wave the moment you
do that you basically double the
frequency of that sine wave so a lot of
times my measurements you'll see 120
hertz spike that's basically the
rectifiers inside the power supply that
are doing that conversion from positive
and negative to all positives so we see
that it has that and this is normal and
you're just gonna get that spike in
there
and then you also get the higher
harmonics of that on this thing
so
we go ahead and compare what happens
when we run it through either the
p12 the ps audio or also my lab
generator that being k9801
um we see that the uh uh there's first
of all no difference between all three
at high level if you step back
everything's the same these spikes are
there just the same why are there there
again the spikes are generated with in
the power supply
with its own function so you can't fix
it by filtering things on the input it
wasn't something that went from input to
output it's a nature of that power
supply to generate that so uh
you know you're going to get that and we
indeed we do but interesting thing
happened both my lab generator and the
p12 generated a
new spike at 60hz
60hz is the mains frequency in where i
live
and so this is basically a ground loop
uh anytime you introduce
more power supply sources and you mess
around with ac the skin routed from one
place to the other
you you risk changing the differential
changing the residual ground uh voltage
and you cause ground currents to run and
you get you can get spy so a lot of
people think
i can get this ac regenerator and
somehow create some kind of floating ac
by magic that fixes ground up it's the
opposite actually if you could get
unlucky and have ground loop that you
didn't have before so don't assume when
you plug this thing in your noise level
actually went down besides the other
noise issues i showed you it may
actually create noise of of its own or
if you may get lucky and if you have a
ground loop and somehow it vanishes
because of just you know a bunch of
just a weak architecture of audio is
that every device has its own ground
reference and maybe get lucky and they
counteract each other
but it's fascinating in here that you
know what you envision to be that always
a goodness coming out of a series
generator it is not always goodness
all else being equal you won't have
least number of power supplies in your
system don't go keep adding doodads have
that their own power supply the moment
they have their own power supply
you're making your life more more
complicated on this thing
so
we've now gone from raw ac we measured
that quantified that this device is a
mixed bag not a great device per se but
you know it did reduce
distortion
um we then walked our uh down a pipeline
into the audio device and examined the
the
power supply and by the way none of
these are
seen in the output of our audio
equipment because all of it gets
filtered again to get us high
performance output but we're going to
test for that
so
i assume that if you're going to go
spend six thousand dollars on a a power
tweak you also have great audio
equipment because if you don't have
great audio equipment you should go
spend your money on great audio
equipment
and uh one of the reviews actually talks
about that's posted on ps audio site is
a headphone amplifier so i said well
okay i'll use a headphone amplifier so i
have a topping a 90
headphone amplifier it's a
state-of-the-art headphone amplifier as
far as measured performance
uh measured with my raw ac again but
nothing going through any power region
and we see it's got a little bit of you
know mains hum here but it's at minus
140 db
which is incredibly low and then we see
the distortions are all also minus 140
db remember minus 115 is a threshold of
hearing there's
we cannot perceive anything lower than
115 no matter what so these things are
25 degree below that so these spikes are
just other art utterly inaudible and
this performance is superb you can see a
number of zeros in here and thd plus n
and a sine out of
120 db
so
let's go ahead and
oops i have a typo in here i wrote p15
it should say p12
so we now go ahead and run this uh um
the a90 again
same test but now power it through uh
psrd or p12 and we see the distortions
are where they are but look at this
little ground loop got worse in here
and that's what i showed earlier that
you can make your ground loop worse but
again it is extremely low so it's not
creating an audible problem but
technically
it degraded performance just a little
bit but our hearing threshold is very
high at low frequencies so it needs to
be way up here before we hear ground
loops
um
in the past people have complained
whenever i do one of these tests
somebody says you should have tested
this you should have tested that and one
of the
common uh retorts is that all you test
at just one frequency which is true in
this case
it's only one kilohertz so i ran a
secondary test where i sweep from 20
hertz to 20 kilohertz and measure
harmonics and and noise but importantly
the measurement bandwidth is 90
kilohertz or more than four times the
audible bandwidth that way i can capture
the harmonics of 20 kilohertz if they
exist
and when i was measuring this i was
surprised that uh i expected to be to
see no difference between
the power generated by the
psr p12 and uh raw ac turns out right he
was actually cleaner across all of them
i was like whoa
besides the mains noise which got a
little bit worse in here something else
has happened what's going on so i went
ahead and looked at the spectrum of one
kilohertz coming out of a 90 when it's
powered by either
raw ac or powered by ps audio p12 and if
you look in here there's a spike in here
around uh 67 kilohertz 68 kilohertz
that's coming out of the uh
a90 and that spike has gotten two or
three db worse when you were powered by
ps audio
uh i don't know why it got worse
and i suspect this frequency is the
switching frequency of some regulator
using a90 it's at 68 kilohertz and 120
db down so it's certainly not an audible
concern but certainly measurable thing
and for whatever reason
psi
aggravates that by just the hair um so
funny again of counter intuitive thing
um
not an actual concern but hey if you're
going to talk about how you have lower
distortion ac and
we measured it and
it actually is not the case
now at this point people say well your
measurements must be wrong because i
clearly hear it
uh well you're not alone i'm i'm sure if
if somebody played some music for me and
then said let me hook up this ac cleaner
this output is so much cleaner than than
your raw ac
play the same clip against and now what
do you think i think many of us will
hear an improvement
why do we hear an improvement because
when we
change something in the system
we all then try to figure out what that
change is and you change the way you
listen
you literally your brain goes from
enjoyment mode to instrumentation mode
and starts to pay attention trying to
think if the high's any cleaner bases
are better noise level is lower when you
peer into music that way
and change your perception you start to
perceive music differently
when you pay attention to the decay of a
note
you can hear you know where it goes
whereas normally when you were enjoying
it that pluck of guitar would have been
just a ding
but when you change and you're trying to
do a b testing of the system you pay
attention and that thing
you follow it and ignore everything else
in the music to see where that goes
and because you've changed your
perception you actually think
everything sounds better
now the inverse of that happens is that
it's all right now let me go back to the
machine but by now
your brain has put two and two together
cleaner ac equals hearing more detail
blacker background better bass and when
you take it out and you go back to the
old one
it's incredible how the brain also tells
you it's not as good as yeah you took
out you took out the thing that was
improving things now i'm gonna tell you
that it doesn't sound as good
now if you've done that test blind where
you didn't know if the instrument was
the ac regenerator was in or not in
then your brain would try to go to
instrument mode but it would go the
instrument mode for both on the
unmodified and a modified system and it
would actually read the same
improvements in both or lack thereof and
it would get confused to a point where
it would basically generate what we call
random outcome it would be like you know
half the time you thought you guessed
correctly half the time you didn't and
by the way you need to do the test many
times otherwise you could just say once
oh this one is the p12 and it sounded
better no that could have been just a
lucky guess so if you do that test 10
times
you need to get like nine times right
which one's which and basically you will
not so
this is a
fallacy that happens because we're human
uh i've been to audio shows and people
show totally useless stuff
and my brain tells me
that it sounds better because of this
the thing i told you about so knowing
this effective and doesn't guard against
not hearing the improvement
the only thing it does by the way is not
paying attention to what's changed and
i've done that at audio shows where i
just close my eyes i don't listen to the
person saying let me change things i
just listen to the music and all sudden
everything sounds identical um but
anyway
uh so the two are
complete harmony
measurements say this this ac cleaner
has absolutely no benefit and if
anything at times it could make things
worse
and people saying but i got them i put
in my system and it sounds so much
better i hear all these great things
and that's true we believe you that is
exactly what's happening
but it is not reality which means that
when you get out of that mode of being
an instrument you just sit back and
listen to your music system its sound
has not changed it cannot have changed
when i'm showing you instrumentation to
this level detail that says
things have not gotten better it's
your logic that you can't dispute so if
you want to keep swearing that you can't
hear the improvement then have somebody
swap the ac on you 10 times randomly
without you knowing it and you just keep
a log and see if you get 9 out of 10
times right
nobody's ever been able to show that
because it's basically impossible
to do
so
from my point of view these devices do
nothing this is like i don't know the
10th or 15th device i've tested where
there's power condition and power
filters balance power ac regenerators
lab ac regenerates there has not been
even the remotest indication that they
improve the performance of audio some
people will say well aren't there other
devices that may improve sure then there
is a
shades of grey right i should be able to
see some trace of it in the devices that
i test and i've tested a ton of things
tested amplifiers dax
preamps you name it i have
mad power arms everything i've measured
the output eating is unchanged or
slightly worse so
you know given this preponderance of
evidence please please don't spend money
on on these things remember that the
manufacturer doesn't provide a single
test case of either proper listening
tests or measurements that indicates
these devices do any good they just
appeal to your gut to your lay intuition
that these things do well and by the way
it works with me too i look at this
device and i just like to plug it in and
look at the meters that says output is
cleaner it makes me feel better even
though i know it absolutely does nothing
useful
so that's where they sell you know some
people come out and say well they sell a
lot that must work and i'm like no they
sell a lot because
our late intuition
as humans is we think this stuff works
and we buy
so anyway
hopefully you enjoyed this review and
see you in a future video bye-bye